all right let's bring in kerry mccarthy
she's the shadow of climate change
minister kerry mccarthy good morning to
you thank you for being with us just
pick up on what you heard there from
jacob rees-mogg i mean saying the nickel
surgeon's always moaning what's that
going to do trying to keep the union
together well it's obviously very little
in terms of having a constructive
relationship obviously labour supports
the union we want to work with nicola
sturgeon we don't support her calls for
independence but i think they're sort of
name-calling just saying she's
attention-seeking
for pursuing the calls that she's been
elected to to do as an snp politician i
think it's it's pretty juvenile and i
think sadly that's the way the
conservative party leadership contest
seems to be going doesn't it well
personal attacks at some point let's
pick up another big story from this
morning there's bp results uh huge
profits being made obviously labour
party heavily campaigned for a windfall
tax on energy profits that has been
agreed to in part
what happens next to try and make sure
that people's cost of living is is dealt
with well i think people who find it
quite shocking that they're making
profits i think these are the highest
quarterly profits recorded for 14 years
and we've seen the same from shell we've
seen the same from centrica as well so
there's clearly a pattern that they're
doing very well out of this situation
and yet we've got this cost of living
crisis and it's quite scary the extent
to which bills are predicted to go up in
october and then again in january you're
talking about predictions of over three
and a half thousand pounds for for
typical bills and people are just really
really struggling to make ends meet now
that you're hearing stories about people
just giving up on their prepayment
meters and it might be quite small debts
it might be that they just can't afford
15 20 pounds but that's the difference
between being able to heat their homes
and you know turn the lights on and not
so certainly labour's calling for um as
an immediate um
an immediate measure um
scrapping vat on fuel bills for now um
but we're also calling on the government
to bring in an emergency budget and
again it goes back to what i was saying
about what's currently going on in the
conservative party because we can't wait
for we know the bills will be going up
at the start of october we can't wait
for a new prime minister in september to
then assemble a cabinet to then decide
what they're going to do they're in
government now they're meant to be
getting on with dealing with the cost of
living crisis and yet they're not yeah
let's move on to uh what we're seeing on
on some of the streets around the
country people uh striking calling for a
greater um
a wage increase i've seen another
another couple of labour party members
and shadow cabinet members on picket
lines what is the ruling in the labour
party what does kirsten want his
ministers to do when it comes to being
on picket lines well our general line is
we very we support the right to strike
and if unions have taken them balloted
their members and taken a democratic
decision to go on strike then that is
yeah they're well within their rights to
do that we also support the
right of you know we think it's right
for mps to go out and talk to the people
that they represent which is what lisa
and andy was doing this week with a
picture of listening as well doing that
if we can bring it up sorry please
so but really what this comes down to is
the need to actually get a negotiated
deal to get a fair deal for the people
that have gone on strike
and that requires government to actually
step up and encourage people to get
around the negotiating table it
certainly does let's just bring up
though what sir kirsten has said about
the labour party and what they should do
around strike action the labor party in
opposition needs to be the labor party
in power and the government doesn't go
on picket lines i mean this kind of
infighting when the conservative parties
have been disarrayed is not very helpful
to the labour party is it what's going
on i think it's not helpful for the
focus to be on labour's position on this
one clearly it's the government that has
responsibilities you're sitting here
if you look at like grant shapes you
know complete refusal to step into the
room
we're talking about what's happening in
the labor party yeah but i think he's
been quite clear that we do support the
trade union rights we do support workers
um
you know the right that they have to
actually withhold their labor if a
democratic decision has has been maken
and he's been very quite clear um
so why is lisa and andy going to pick
its why was cemetery at pickett's the
other day i mean there are there are
members of the party who want to go and
want to support the strikers more
full-throatedly than secure stamina
wants to why is there that disconnect
well i think i mean keir said yeah as i
understand it was
he was
spoken to lisa and he was quite relaxed
about the the fact that she went out to
talk to the people that she represents
the difference with sam is that he
actually did a whole media round and
came up with policies that hadn't been
cleared by the party and that's just not
something that you do if you're in the
shadow front bench team you have to have
collective responsibility it puts your
colleagues in a very difficult position
if people are just freelancing it and i
think sam did know that that's what he
was doing so that's why he was sad but
you know there was a threat to sack
other people i don't think he's going to
sack lisa nanny but it's very clear what
he says isn't it he doesn't want you
going to the pickets i mean would you do
that to pick up i think there's a
performative element of standing on the
picket line holding up signs when you're
not the one on strike but i think
there's a difference between that and
actually going out and talking to
people and supporting you know i i've
spoken to people i've not been on a
picket line but i've been i've had
conversations with people that are going
out on strike and people um some of the
unions that are talking about possible
strike action in the autumn and i think
that's that's very much my job as a an
mp to do that do you think it's a vote
loser to be full-throatedly behind the
union for the labour party i would like
to think that people recognize the
importance of working people's rights i
mean they were very hard fought for and
particularly when you have
a situation where you've got
skyrocketing inflation you've got the
cost of living crisis that we've already
spoken about it's only fair for people
to be allowed to um ask for that their
wages would um help them meet some of
the cost of that so i think that's
that's incredibly legitimate i think
what's not helpful is when
it would be seen as labour in the
forefront of this as a and taking
attention off the government so
grant chaps would love it to be labour
mps on picket lines with the rail
workers and that be the story because
that means that he can abdicate any
sense of responsibility for
being you know being the one that ought
to be stepping in and finding a solution